herzlich willkommen in meine trocken
heute kommen style dreimal selbst
special ich werde heute wieder etwas
süßes machen wenn du einen kürbiskuchen
machen ohne jetzt denken vielleicht
einige kürbiskuchen das geht ja mal gar
nicht ich werde mich heute vom gegenteil
überzeugen dieser kürbiskuchen ich
nämlich so lecker dass das eigentlich so
mein top favorit unter den kuchen ist
also ich hab dir jetzt schon so oft
gebacken letztes jahr auch schon habt
dann den leuten gar nicht gesagt dass es
in kürbiskuchen ist und wirklich keine
kommt auf die idee dass der kürbis
drinsteckt ihr könnt den kürbis
natürlich auch austauschen zum beispiel
gegen karotten oder gegen zucchini dann
habt ihr eben auch möhren kuchen
ich sage ich jetzt einfach mal die
zutaten und zeigt euch dann wie es
weitergeht
für den rührteig braucht ihr vier eier
210 gramm zucker 180 gramm öl das ist
neutrales sonnenblumenöl
ihr könnt auch theoretisch auch kürbis
öl benutzen oder walnussöl oder so
ähnlich eine packung backpulver 250
gramm mehl einen esslöffel zimt nicht so
ganz nimmt marc letzten weg aber ich
finde der passt hier perfekt rein 80 g
gehackte mandeln 80 gramm gemahlene
mandeln und natürlich ein kürbis ich
habe jetzt hier eine idee davon braucht
ihr 300 gramm
das ist jetzt einer der wiegt etwa 1700
habe ich jetzt gewaschen bei dem dürfte
nämlich die schale mit benutzten und der
kürbis ist auch jetzt auch das erste was
sich vorbereiten muss wie gesagt ich
dass ein hocker wobei dem darf mal die
schale mit essen
ich finde er eignet sich für den kuchen
eigentlich so am besten weil er eben
auch diese schöne orangener farbe hat
vermisst er auf pump sehr hart
das kann sich hier raus
und dann schneide ich mir den ganz
großen wird andere kürbissorten müsste
wie gesagt schälen zucchini können sie
schon mal auftragen lassen bei karotten
wird es auch erzählen und die stücke
werde ich jetzt ganz kurz im thermomix
klein hacken können wir in jedem anderen
mixa machen aber die schale ist ziemlich
hart also das packt nicht jeder mixa
wenn ihr an den mixer hat er es nicht
packt würde ich an ihrer stelle des
kleinen rasten oder eben kurz vor kochen
und so sieht es dann aus wenn der kürbis
klein gehackt ist ihr seht die richtig
tolle orangene farbe und es richtig
schön saftig
ich habe schon mal eine kuchenform
vorbereitet ich nehme da eine kastenform
und zwar ist es eine etwas größere
kastenform die hat so 30 zentimeter in
der länge und die habe ich jetzt bereits
gewählt und gefettet als zuerst
gefährdet und angenehmen in meine
richtung gebe ich jetzt die eier und die
werden dann wie immer zuerst mit dem
zucker verrühren
vielleicht auch schon das war kein
biskuitteig werden
und jetzt kommen einfach alle anderen
zutaten mit rein
und jetzt hat es einfach alles
eingeführt
sobald alles fertig da teig fertig und
kann ihnen die form gefüllt werden
jetzt mache ich wie gesagt in meiner
kastenform ihr könnte auch eine andere
form nehmen darunter springform oder ein
backblech wie gesagt hat diese
kastenform die perfekte größe tier hat
eine länge von 30 cm
da passt der teig richtig gut rein dann
einfach kurz bisschen hin und her
stützen
damit sich der teig gleichmäßig verteilt
und ich sehe auch schon dass ich
ziemlich viel teig für die backform aber
das ist und feste rateike so ein
feuchter teig und netz und bisky takter
eben nur locker ist der wird jetzt so
bei 170 grad bitte nicht höher bei ober
unterhitze etwa 75 minuten gebacken
danach mache ich auf jeden fall die
stäbchen probe und stammt geht es gleich
weiter
der kuchen habe ich jetzt schon etwas
abkühlen lassen
der hand stützt sich jetzt einfach aus
der form heraus und dann gebe ich ihm
auf meiner kuchenform das richtig schön
weich den denke ich jetzt mit einem tuch
ab und schloss ihn abkühlen und später
kommt da eben noch der guss drauf und
dann dieser fertig wenn der kuchen dann
fertig gebacken ist könnt ihr natürlich
auch einfach so essen ihr könnt ihn mit
puderzucker bestäuben oder mit einer
show côte d'azur überziehen
ich mag ihn allerdings am liebsten mit
einer zitrone puderzucker davor weil ich
finde dass diese freundliche glasur
einfach perfekt dazu passt und rennt
gerne gesträuch das ganze dann noch mit
etwas schokolade und wie ich das mache
zeige ich euch jetzt
und dafür braucht ihr 100 gramm
puderzucker zwei bis drei esslöffel
zitronensaft und einen teelöffel zimt
die zitrone habe ich hier drin und geht
die hier mit dazu seit dem 10
so sollte er im griff es seien also
nicht zu dünn
und dann wird der kuchen damit um hilfe
und dann wer möchte nimmt sich etwas
zarter schokolade und brachte die
einfach so da drüber und ich gebe dann
ganz gern noch ein paar wandel stiftet
darüber wenn ihr vorher zum beispiel mit
walnüssen gearbeitet habt also wenn ihr
charakter mal wahl müsse mit in der tat
gegeben hat dann wird er jetzt ganz
schön so was helfen da drauf geben und
es eben richtig schön dekorieren die
mandeln muss jetzt ein bisschen an
drücken
und wenn der kuchen dann vollständig
abgekühlt ist und der cruze trocken ist
ist es da wir bereit ganz einfach
gemacht und schmeckt sehr lecker
also all diejenigen die noch nie einen
kürbis kuchen gegessen haben
was sind dieses rezept unbedingt mal
ausprobieren also ich verspreche euch
dass der kuchen euch schmecken wird und
das ist eine wirklich große überraschung
werden diejenigen nicht wissen das war
ein kürbis drinsteckt ich hoffe dieses
rezept gefällt euch und ihr probiert es
wirklich mal aus ich wünsche euch auch
einen ganz schönen sonntag wir sehen uns
morgen schon wieder mit einem neuen
video